hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round 2 of the single
cup it's Fabiana corona versus eonni
Pony she the only person who lost a game
in round 1
Knepper lost to Annan we've shown that
game after that
well pretty big blunder allowing honor
to play beef I would check but now let's
see how he fares against the former
vultures championship challenger and can
he bounced back in the tournament so
without further ado let's just do a nice
coin flip so we can get started
alrighty then and now let's get on with
the game Fabi with the white pieces
opened with e4 and nipple goes for c5
the Sicilian defense is on the board we
have Knight to f3 d6 and now d4
everything pretty standard captures
captures and Knight to f6 we have nice
to see three and a six we have the
dnieper of defense on the board with h3e
5 by neppo pushing the knight back
Knight to b3 and mount Bishop to e7
we have g4 by Fabi already preparing to
push on the King side and now b5 in fo
does the same on the Queen side with g5
Knight f2 b7 and here there is one game
where Knight to d5 was played he was
played in 2016
between Amelie Karthikeyan and alexandra
duchenko don't check or want that game
very nice with a nicely with the black
pieces but here Fabi plays h4 it's a new
move in the position and it is of move
tendered we have a completely new game
so nice to be 6 pineapple and now bush
of the e3 Fabi develops prepares the
eliminated and I can be 6 if if he
doesn't want to allow nice to see 4 with
Bishop to e6 with more control on the C
4 square and here Fabi decides to trade
with bushel characters Queen captures
and now Queen to f3 with b4 by nepo
Knight to d5 and now a trade on the d5
square Bishop characterís pawn captures
and Knight to d7 now now the knight can
come to c5 with queenside castle mine
Apple and now a5 preparing a for with
King the b1 and now
Neto starts pushing on the Queen side
with a for attacking the knight
and the Knights to d2 from d2 tonight
can come to see four or four depending
on what black plays with night the c5 by
neppo and here now preparing b3 and
Bishop to d3 there's no good way to
prevent it so you have to allow it
nepo pushes b3 and I mean why not we
have well we don't have castles of
opposite sides as Nepos King is still in
the center but it's very unlikely that
nipple will Castle queenside so why not
attack on the Queen side see chapters on
b3 with a character son b3 and now a
three usual way where how you prevent
your phone structure to being completely
ruined and now although you can castle a
first nipple was a rook to a for a nice
rook lift and now Knight to e4 offering
a trade with captures captures and now
finally nipple castles preparing to
bring the other look into the game
depending on what a worldwide place we
have rook h2 g1 now preparing h6 in the
h5 and g6 and here
Queen to e7 maybe with ideas of of doing
some crazy things on the Queen side with
h5 by by karana preparing g6 she wants
to do the same on the King side as an
epithet on the Queen side so never
prevents that he pushes g6 himself and
now rook to d3
preparing to capture on b3 so net for
defensive we've looked to be 8 and now
far betrays wants to open up the H file
with HK % g 6h chapters on g6 and now
here Fabi
probably should have gone for Luke to h1
maybe create some chances over over
along the H file which never can
probably prevent with a bishop f8 and
the Bishop g7 he's gonna guard the h8
squared this way but here Khurana did it
a bit differently he first played Queen
to g2 and the idea is still you still
want to go to the H file but from the
second rank you can push f3 or f4 so the
Queen will also be able to to guard the
King side well the Queen side but the
king is on the Queen side but here it
doesn't work so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find
there I say it the winning move for
Nepal in this position and you know
don't just take a few seconds it's
really a really a tough one so you take
even a minute or two if you need it you
know feel free to pause the video now so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations if you found Queen to a
seven Queen to a seven is just a monster
move to find so congratulations if you
found it and if you just want to enjoy
the show here never should have gone for
rook captures on a three and now you
have to capture it otherwise you get a
look at one mate
so after pawn captures Queen captures on
83 again threatening Queen to a to check
here you have to play f3 it's a good
thing bobby's queen is now on g2 this is
why he put it there to defend the a to
square and now comes the move you had to
find because you want to play b2 and the
Queen a1 but you can play this since the
Queen is guarding although all the
squares here and also if you put b3 you
just lose the Queen right away
so here the correct move is Queen to a7
it's the only move that wins and it
prevents the Queen from helping out with
the defense because the rook is under
attack here you can play a few things
you could play rook gd1 just get the
rock out of the way so you can start
getting your Queen into the game but it
doesn't work here you can put b2 because
your queen is no longer an a3 and now
how do you prevent rook to a want a
queen to a-1 you really don't after King
c2 you just play be one Queen and after
rook captures now you play Queen a to
check and well you while you can capture
the Queen you can also just do a forced
mate after king c3 are gonna go rook c8
in before you're just gonna infiltrate
with the Queen Queen c4 check King a3
and now after check King b2 you will
deliver rook to a to mate so very nice
meeting idea and also after this Quinte
is 7 move if you don't play rook GD 1
there's very few things you can play you
could play rogue d2 maybe try and cover
the secondary maybe prevent even be 2
but then you get rook a8 threatening
rook e1 may to the punk covers the C 2
square and after came to c1 you try and
run away then you get Queen C 5 check
came back to be one you get Queen to a3
with the same
idea of mate and now there's no escape
the Queen covers the C 1 square and
whatever you do you're just getting
mated you you have to start giving up
material wood white and it's all over
so after Queen 2 G 2 rook captures on a
three wins the game on the spot but you
have to find Queen back to a7 otherwise
it doesn't work
net what didn't find it and he played
Bishop to f8 he thought I will just
controlled it on the Kings side
I always need this bishop here so he can
cover the h8 square and now he will go
on the attack but now
Fabi gets a chance to consolidate its
first f3 now already he doesn't have to
waste a move on f3 later as the Queen I
already can help out with the defense
and now the same idea no longer works we
have looked the c-4 by neppo and now
troop to h1 now it's Fabi who's on the
attack we have Queen to c7 transferring
the rook and queen over to the C file
maybe with some rook to c2 ideas but now
Queen to H - favi now threatens
checkmate
so Bishop to g7 the move never prepared
so now Queen to h7 doesn't really do
anything you're just gonna play King a
fake and now you have to go back to help
out with the defense Queen back to h2
King g8 and so on
so after Bishop to g7 fabric plate Queen
back to e - and now or never just
repeated Bishop to f8 if you try look
the seat to him seems like a nice idea
but just Rudy - and you don't really do
anything here would black you're just
gonna have to go back Roxy for Roxy 5
and white will then again play Rudy 3 or
something but after Queen e2 we had
Bishop to f8 like we said and now Queen
back to h2 with Bishop to g7 Queen back
to e to Bishop to f8 Queen to h2 and
after Bishop to g7 it was in this
position that Fabi and therefore agreed
to a draw which is seen if you've missed
the rook captures on a3 idea seems like
a really timid game you know
everything's still on the board both
players have nothing to go on
and they just decided to draw but it's
really amazing that that such a move did
not take place if if nipple had more
time on the clock it's it's a move you
really really want to calculate that
Farouk a force mg - but
still captures captures captures and
then after f3 you have to find rook to
a7 but finding a sort of Queen to a7
finding such a move from this position
where white place Queen to g2 is were
obviously very very difficult as both
Fabia and they promised it but again
congratulations to everyone who found it
as it's really just a beautiful
continuation so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it could have gone
differently but you know it's good for
kuranda it isn't but it's a shame for
Nepal that it didn't as he would bounce
back into the into the tournament after
his loss in round one I would also like
to thank Krishna Subramanian and Curt
Mason for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see you soon have a
very nice game prepared it's not from
the single cup but I'm sure you're gonna
enjoy it so you know stay tuned thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day